for me watching your show one of the
things that I find myself drawn into and
kind of attracted to is all the ritual
that goes along with Muslim prayer and I
think you know I I was raised Catholic
very Catholic I'm sort of drawn to this
whole concept of everyone comes together
at the mosque and and the the rugs and
the praying and the you know the the
ritual of it seems very calming and
welcoming to me yeah and I think that's
because I grew up with you're going to
get in this Pew it's really hard wood
it's not comfortable I mean there are
some things about it like in for example
in Catholicism you can pray wherever you
are yes you can literally be in an
elevator and just cross yourself and
you're done yeah like it's uh so it's
very user friendly that way totally I
mean I don't need a rug yeah I don't
need to be know which direction is
Easter you know what I mean there's
nothing they made it they dumbed it down
so much in Catholic autism well yeah you
know we have two different we have that
kind of like you can you know direct
line anytime you can just put your hands
out like put your hands out making this
little kind of v-shape and you can just
ask God for anything that's anywhere and
then you you also can pray anywhere and
you see that a lot in New York there's
just like a guy in the middle of the
sidewalk praying and uh just in
everybody's way but he'll do it right
because people I've seen people just
straight up and I actually had um one of
my dad's friends this must have been
like 2007 he'd just stop and pray
anywhere and a couple people call the
cops on him they're like we don't know
what's going on we were
we see two officers come just because
he's praying in the middle of the park
so what did they think did they think
they're just yeah the kid lost his mind
or he's having an episode yeah they're
like what's going on you know and then
and then I think some someone was afraid
or whatever but it's funny like I I was
kind of wanting to get a cab this was a
couple weeks ago and there was this taxi
cab pulled over and and the light was
off so it was available but then you
know I looked in and there was a couple
they were like looking in they were like
this guy's gone crazy and then I walked
by and I look at him and he's like
praying on the steering wheel but I
could tell like with what he was doing
with his head like what point of the
prayer he was in and I was like oh he's
almost done like I'm about to get this
cap like they they went it was a long
block long block and they just start
walking towards Houston I'm like people
are gonna be sweating and I'm like you
guys don't even understand this is the
last part of the prayer he's gonna be
done in 10 seconds he finishes he looks
at me I'm like yo and hop right in right
right right so your knowledge your your
deep understanding oh god of the prayer
cycle got you a cab save me from going
on the subway it was it was unbelievable
but yeah the uh the carpets are soft so
no hard wooden pews when you go in the
mosque and I think that the the ritual
is the most beautiful part of it to me I
think that's what the cleaning yourself
too I mean I I was not aware there's so
much I've learned from watching your
show
um and and this is one of the things I
really love about it I learn a lot the
show is not it's so far from preaching
it's so far from you know trying to
instruct it's it's about people it's
about people really funny people and a
lot of awkward situations and I know
that you're uh a Larry David fan it
evokes some of the in a great
comparisons to just awkward great comedy
situations and Humanity it's just you
know in the program in the show
I love the fact that I watch it and when
I come away I feel
I know not just your you know your
characters better but I feel like I have
a better understanding of what it might
be like to be Egyptian Muslim and come
here to the United States you know yeah
well I think like part of the design for
us was making it clear that we're kind
of giving people a window into some of
those rituals into some of the rules
into some of what's going on and then
the second we introduce that we're
making it really clear that everyone
here is doing it wrong and I think
that's what makes it funny where it's
like I'm going to show you the thing but
then also it's so clear that this is not
instructive because man these people are
dealing with their egos on level 10 and
they're making a mess wherever they go
and I think that's that to me is what
makes it a fun thing to make because I
never want to be in a situation where I
need to feel like an educator or preachy
or whatever because all that shit's just
like it's anti-comedy but I do think
what I've really enjoyed you know in
terms of looking at the history of
Comedy is I think the idea of a
character going to church in and of
itself is a joke like it's a joke that
someone would believe in the Unseen and
I think here we've kind of flipped the
joke where it's like none of the Unseen
thing is a given like that relationship
isn't what we're making fun of we're
kind of making fun of everything that
happens under it and I think that um has
opened up situations that I feel get to
be unique to our show because we're
we're kind of we have this different
um machine as to like what we're
interrogating and and I think yeah a lot
of people have been like dude your
show's my favorite show about Catholic
guilt you know oh and then because it's
all the same yeah it's all it's guilt
we're all I mean it's so funny to me is
anyone who was raised in religion uh has
these ideals that they're supposed to
live up to and then we all have the
workarounds yeah and that's the part
that cracks me up is all the characters
in your show doing workarounds for yeah
I don't drink but I'm gonna drink or I'm
not supposed to really have sex but I'm
gonna have a lot of sex
um but we're gonna figure this out we're
going to work this out later and I think
that's every religion is people you're
handed these lists of very severe rules
early on and you can have every
intention of being down with that but
then you have your yeah we're going to
work around that but still I am a devout
Muslim but I man I'm I'm going to it's
Ramadan but I'm gonna eat yeah I'm gonna
because that's a Big Mac and we'll
figure this out later you know what I
mean it's this feeling of like
constantly like refinancing with God you
know
and I think that's really like that's a
great way to put it yes yes and and it's
just probably yeah
by the end you're just terribly in debt
you just I mean I think we're all doing
that you know we're all constantly
saying look I'm gonna just put this on
my tab yeah just put this on my tab God
and we'll figure this out because I just
had a ninesome they were I had sex with
eight different people I had a nine some
and um and then I had a cocaine enema
but we're gonna figure this out
so
um because I love you God and trust me
I'm very devout
we're gonna figure this out is I mean
that's the energy you know for for I
think that's what keeps us all going I
love what it's something that uh
fascinates me because I see it in
Catholicism as well the double standard
with men and women because it's
something that I saw growing up where it
I mean Rami his you
party you go out with your friends and
your parents think oh that Romney it's
just adorable and then your sister who's
on the I think on the show she's you
know 25 26 yeah and just very attractive
modern woman if she wants to do anything
it's where are you going you have to be
back by nine and that exists uh you know
when I was growing up
my uh
I know my mom like my brothers and I
would be chewing gum yeah and she
wouldn't say a word and then if one of
my sisters started chewing gum she'd be
like spit had come out yeah you know you
want people to think you're trash you
know you're not some common ragamuffin I
mean that's how my mom spoke gun chewing
is very ragamuffin Behavior it is yeah
and we won't have that just to be clear
there'll be no Rag and muffery around
here so just work that into Rami yeah
it's one of the characters to start
talking about I'm no ragamuffin and
people say the writing is off this year
what happened and then you see the Conan
O'Brien writing credit at the end
special cultural Consultants please put
me in as a special cultural consultant
done yeah yeah just in the in one of the
prayers there's many mentions of
ragamuffin Tom fularicha Canary people I
I think they lost the thread this year
what happened did you watch till the end
I did did you see that Conan O'Brien
cultural credit
might be a problem no but what you're
talking about is is amazing to me
because I think that is something that
in making the show so many people will
relate to that thing even that that does
disparity between men and women because
obviously and I think we see this more
and more especially lately that's a real
American problem as well I think the way
that in the microcosm of a family you
know how are the sons treated and how
are the daughters treated and it's
something that I think we put on
um you know this Muslim family and I
think that obviously there's some
comfort in in kind of this like I think
there's an American Comfort in being
able to say oh wow like look how that is
in the Middle East because there's kind
of all these things of like oh women
there can't drive you know and then you
kind of start to break that down and
you're like well no that's only just in
Saudi and then you're like oh wait won't
Saudi not women can drive and abortion
seems to be just about as hard in both
places you know and then you start to
kind of zoom out and you're like whoa we
have a lot of these problems and I think
that's part of why the show resonates
because it's at first you're like oh I'm
learning about this other thing but then
you dig into it and you're like oh wait
this is in my family too you know this
is here too and and I think that starts
to kind of open up what I hope could be
a bridge